cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com this is an existential
crisis we have that we need to address
lampedusa the migrant crisis nurse says
welcome everyone as Islands residents
complain they have to wait for care more
than 12 thousand migrants have arrived
on the Italian island of lampedusa in
the past week putting the staff like
Franco galletto under serious strain
you may have seen the story there's an
island in Italy it is relatively close
to Tunisia it has 6550 or so residents
and there are now 12
000 migrants economic migrants who have
come in most of them fighting age males
I'm sorry man look there's videos of
people singing barricades there's a
video going viral of people fighting
that is not from this island
that was an older video but there is a
video going viral right now that I
haven't confirmed where it shows people
setting up barricades and the argument
is
look these myres have started setting up
their own territorial zones
you get 12 000 people into your
community of six thousand your community
does not exist anymore it's over the
will of the people right democracy okay
well these people are here if you don't
believe in borders they're going to vote
for whatever they want I'll tell you
this they're gonna vote take your stuff
they're going to come in they're going
to take your stuff they're going to
leave they're gonna go somewhere else
right and what's the number one thing
that that you know the people in charge
are trying to do
take away our opportunity take away our
ability to defend ourselves in in case
of any Invasion like this right when I
see someone like Gavin news from all his
pages is like we need to eliminate guns
and do this the other thing it's like
that that you can name 10 different
things that put us in a bad position if
we don't have guns this is another one
well I mean an invasion of another
if there's if the videos are true that
they're starting to seize territory
now you're getting into war and that's a
scary thought yeah someone referred to
the migrants that just came in today as
reinforcements yeah I mean this island
is effectively occupied by migrants from
Northern Africa that that's what this is
I mean the interior minister of France
went there today and he said you know we
should help Italy we should keep our
borders open and it's very important you
know the thing is when you get to Italy
it's a pathway into the EU but the EU
says Italy you have to process all the
Asylum Seekers and so they're presuming
that all the migrants there are going to
apply for Asylum which I just think
statistically is not going to happen and
so this becomes an incredible problem
that communities are having to deal with
you were talking about wanting to do
things locally these 6 000 people are
now having to accommodate 12 000 people
possible that doesn't it's not gonna
happen it's not just that it's that if
we're supposed to you see what AOC was
saying in New York when she said
everyone's screaming at her saying get
these illegal immigrants out of our city
their resources are strained and she
says we're going to give them work
rights we are going to give them more of
our tax resources and we're going to
give them a special protected status
she's yelling over the people who are
screaming at her to stop she does not
care
so now think about what's going on with
with the EU this problem's been
happening for for a decade plus it got
really really bad several years ago and
it's not being abated
if they follow the course they have in
many other countries what's going to
happen is the people who are there which
be given special rights
what happens when you have a piece of
land with 12 000 people
who are not allowed to vote and there
are 6 500 people who do vote eventually
the 12 000 people say there's more of us
than there are of you and we now get the
right to vote so what is what will
likely happen in these circumstances is
that I'm sorry your laws are only
meaningful so long as they can be
enforced your borders are only
enforced twelve thousand people show up
by all means your law still exists for
you not for them they don't know your
laws and they don't care and if they
want to set up barricades and take
territory they'll just do it
people need to understand that when it
comes to law it's just what's in your
brain right if you if if you go to a if
you're like from West Virginia go to
Ohio Law's different
you might just mean you didn't even know
it was illegal let's say Pennsylvania
you're allowed to you're allowed to
carry a gun in Pennsylvania not in New
Jersey you didn't know that well you
went somewhere else the laws were
different so what what this what this is
is what that woman who went to New
Jersey and had a gun and didn't know was
illegal and got arrested she did not
know the law of this other place now
what happens if 10 000 people cross into
New Jersey is that one cop gonna be able
to stop anybody your law only applies to
you who know it and follow it and I mean
to add on top of this most people don't
even know when new laws get passed
anyway especially when they ban guns
because it's like how are you supposed
to follow all that stuff they expect you
to be a good app it doesn't but yes but
my point here is this if 12 000 people
come into lampedusa do you think these
12 000 people know what the laws are do
you think that do they care so are they
going to be probably evil too some
probably will just try to take what's
theirs or take what they want or you you
know you're going to deal with a lot of
hostility there if 12 000 people that
don't have much are in a place that has
a lot of resources it doesn't you know
doesn't the EU already subsidize the
residences to house immigrants so I mean
we already know the first thing that
they're going to do they're going to
start making these Locals House these
people in their homes yeah the
expectation is that you got to put four
each house has to you know we have
double the uh people in our our country
now so you gotta put four people into
each house and if you read all the
mainstream media articles that came out
about it today they all say but what
about the Tunisia deal and this was the
idea of the UN president uh Von laterson
I can never say her name but she and uh
the prime minister of Italy were working
on a deal with Tunisia because Tunisia
is the biggest Gateway for all of this I
mean this is where Smugglers
headquarters people in who are displaced
within Africa and know to go to Tunisia
and then potentially get into Italy
there and they were going to sit offer
them tunisia's economy as in shambles
and they're saying we'll give you a lot
of money to stop these boats from coming
over but we know I mean we talked about
this that that ultimately means that
Tunisia is like well when we need more
money we'll just let the migration go
back up the the deal hasn't been
brokered it's getting stopped installed
in Brussels But ultimately this is a
terrible system it's similar to having
uh malware in your Casino thing where
you can say give me money okay I fixed
the problem just kidding it's not I want
money again like this system is broken
and we know it and the best that they
can do is to say please we'll give you
money to stop the boat well it didn't
work for New York right no he was saying
bring all the immigrants in and then now
we're gonna we're gonna subsidize you to
to house them and now he's saying I
don't see an end to this he said New
York is a sanctuary City and then
started busting migrants to suburbs of
New York and Upstate New York he said
this is everyone else's problem 110 000
migrants have come through New York in
the last year and at any given time the
state New York City is carrying between
four between 50 and 60 000 migrants it's
got to be somewhere and now they're
kicking out veterans out of hotels to
you know put the migrants in and New
York's already just in disrepair there's
the videos of the rats running around
that's awesome for the sidewalks
crumbling and you can see like this
Casey neistat posted this crazy video
and I'm like how did he get this video
he sees the sidewalk is is crumpled and
he he pushes into it and it just Falls
straight down and he sticks his camera
into the underground like piping and
everything and he was like the sidewalks
are scary in New York's like well it's
only going to get worse brother dude
thinking about this intense over popular
this migration a thousand years ago if
you have 20 000 people arrive on your
island of 6 000 people you fight you you
pull out your weapons and defend your
Island so they don't War yes of course
it would be an actor but the difference
now I'm told to do that the difference
now is we have telephones we have
Internet we know that they're not there
to kill that's not I mean obviously they
didn't come they would have been doing
it if that was the that's not the it
doesn't seem like it but we need to
understand the history of what happens
when you let rapid migration encroach on
people's territory if we don't accept
and acknowledge what has happened in the
past it is very likely that it will
happen again in the future but we can
prevent it if we start working on it now
what's happening right now is this is
this is this is the challenge nobody
wants anybody to die so you have these
people on boats and and the question is
what do you do turn the boat I think you
turn turn the boats back around that's
it simple you say hey go back whatever
not we can't handle this but there's the
the the the the challenge now of they
they will Beach these boats We Can't
Stop all of them I mean it's Italy so I
shouldn't say we but the people there
can't stop all of them what do you do we
don't want anybody getting hurt the
problem is you've had these videos
especially in the southern border of
Mexico where they're smashing through
the barriers and fighting with the
border border guards and so the argument
is because they don't have guns of
violent incursion into Sovereign
territory by another group of people is
like just let it happen that's insane to
me but I'm not gonna pretend to have the
answers because like like I said
nobody wants the violence to break out
nobody wants violence to break out but I
fear this will make it inevitable
because the people who are there on the
island are going to need food they're
going to need shelter and they're not
getting it there's 12 000 of them you're
gonna probably see attacks on the locals
you're going to see people get their
property taken from them and the people
who are there are going to start
fighting violence is inevitable when
people violence is inevitable when
people get desperate and they don't have
resources it's it's an inevitable
unfortunately it's great to be like I I
love love and peace I mean I promote it
every single night on tour it's the
first thing that I want to promote but
violence is inevitable when when you
have people that are desperate and they
need to survive themselves right 12 000
people on an island they need to survive
I think I think the issue here some
people may be a bit more conspiratorial
I think it's more so that they just
don't care the the government of Italy
they're just like look I'm overwhelmed I
can't deal with this I know Georgia
Malone we don't care they went down
there this is from the BBC yes yesterday
Georgia Maloney went to the island she's
the Prime Minister send these people
back I know she's hardcore I mean and
that was what she campaigned on she
campaigned on an I will stop illegal
immigration platform so this is a big
test for her uh her government in
particular one one of the things I think
the challenges she faces and it reminds
me a lot of what's going on in Texas
with the floating barrier is you know
there have been times where she has been
like I'm gonna deploy a naval blockade
so people can't come we'll turn the
boats back you know you can't come here
uh Florida has a policy where you you
can't take a boat from Haiti to get here
they will turn the boat back you it
doesn't count basically uh in Texas uh
Greg Abbott's in big trouble because he
put up this thousand foot orange buoy uh
barrier in the Rio Grande and initially
the doj said you have to take down we're
going to sue you because it's inhumane
yeah this is bad we should we shouldn't
stop people from swimming and his
response was you're the you're saying
it's inhumane because the swim is
dangerous so therefore the deterrent is
a good thing because then people don't
attempt it right and they change their
mind they said actually no know you
needed like the Army Corps of Engineers
to design this raft and really you
violated a congressional law I mean
they'll twist whatever they want to
ultimately get the effect of allowing
illegal immigration to continue to the
detriments of the communities that are
having to uh accommodate these people
and having to provide the resources that
they themselves probably don't have this
makes me think of in lampedusa this is
like if you're a play Civilization
there's a technique in that called a
cultural you can flip a city to your
side with cultural pressure and now I'm
wondering if that's actually in the game
what you're not seeing is the the
migration that's happening but it's like
land produces closer to Tunisia than it
is to Italy in the in the game this is
more akin to just attacking the city so
in but it's with unarmed civilians
that's why it's not really there's no
well so so in Civilization I don't know
about the later civilizations but in
earlier games I know this for sure I
don't know if I've played the later ones
enough if you send units into enemy
borders and fortify them you take that
land and it's a declaration of War so
sending even non-military into their
country unless you have open borders
policy yeah but then but then they all
come in and then they all surround the
city and they don't attack the city they
just start taking the land and then it
results in in work question the cultural
thing is more about the people in the
city like your way of life better and
vote to join you but if the people in
the city are my my people in your city
then of course they're gonna like my way
is better than yours but anyway I don't
know you're probably right did you guys
know
um
all right never mind you got to put
yourself in the shoes of of the people
that it's happening to like imagine
you're sitting in your neighborhood with
your gate and your gate opens up and
twice as many people are about to enter
your gate that live in your gate what do
you what do you do if you're the one
that's dealing with that it's so easy
for us to be halfway across the world
and think about that happening right but
it's starting to happen in New York City
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time